yo all the way from the 212 to you it's
your boy jay mills and make sure you
check me out on the bootleg kev podcast
boulevard podcast special guest in here
my guy jay mills welcome back sir yeah
always always first episode was
legendary
yeah man i got in a lot of trouble for
some that i didn't even say but i
guess i said it
and it got spun a different way i had
some media training since like
june
what did you get in trouble for saying
i'm not going to say it because i might
get in trouble again
did you well you talked about a lot that
media training right there boy i'm good
you talked about a lot no you know just
the whole when i when we was having uh
rap albums discussion and we was talking
about like the jay and the kanye and
the writing stuff if we're gonna say
quentin miller did this for so-and-so
then
why people don't say this for this not i
say it like i'm
smart enough to know kanye west doesn't
write for jay-z we're all smart enough
to know that
but like once the interview came out i
looked i was like oh
i said a lot of in that interview i
put a lot of put a lot of respect on
people's names in that interview but
that wasn't the
that wasn't the focal point that's not
that's not what we're gonna get we're
gonna you said basically in metaphorical
terms you basically said this person
writes for this person
so i had to kind of just eat that i
didn't jump in the comments and go back
and forth you was like i get it
no
bite back from any of the young money
stuff you shared
nah nah
nah i did feel like i did feel like
wayne had kind of like took a shot at me
when he said uh
i could
i could flip a j mills to a meek
mill when i first heard it i was like
hold on what that's about but then i
thought about it i was like nah i know
wayne that's not it's not that's not
real i didn't hear this i didn't hear
that bar what what was this on one of
his new verses i think it was on his
latest journey put out but then i'm
smart enough to know wayne and it's like
when i thought about it it's like even
if that is what he said
i'm not mad at that like because when
you met me i was like aj mills and you
took me and took me to another level
so
so even and i'm gonna keep it real even
if wayne was to diss me i'm gonna keep
it real
just where i'm at in my life right now
and being like respectful on some
like you gave me like a platform you
like kind of help
rebrand me
i don't even think i would i don't even
think i would go back at him
that's out of respect for him i just
would be like
uh you got that off let's go good
lighter blown up man
it's not like you hate me it's not like
you ain't got no love for me no more
right you know what i'm saying so why
feed into it like that i still speak to
him i just uh
spoke to mack though they shout out the
mac man shout out to gutter gutter
little wayne's birthday was recently
yeah yeah happy happy belated happy
belated the way man no another another
lap around the sun it's always good to
see somebody make it to another year so
yeah well there it is yeah i was like i
was like man i wonder how this is gonna
uh
some of the stories you shared with some
dan you wanna know some remember when i
hit you when you announced you was
leaving the station i was like yo bro
did i get you in any trouble with the
interview like i had to hit him i was
like yo did i say anything that got you
in trouble at the station
he was like nah i got some whole other
in the works right now i don't even
worry about it i was like all right i'm
just and i'm right i'm back on the
station then
let me go
except for i'm doing it in my
tournaments
congratulations on that man
congratulations on that
yeah no no no that was just
you know some corporate budget cut
you know that happens it
happens man in any business
it happens entertainment specifically
radio specifically everyone's you know
cutting budgets how do you feel about uh
being back on on on the station i mean
it's cool you know i launched the show
and then they picked it up as an
affiliate so it's dope to be able to be
like hey well like
i am on the station but i don't work for
them
so i'm on every night
but i don't work for it for them so the
good parts about being on the station
are there
some of the cool relationships i still
have i mean i i never lost any
relationships at the station it's just
now i kind of the that i don't like
to do
or that i wouldn't like about dealing
with you know having like
all staff meetings and blogging and
and like stuff i don't want to do i
don't have to do any of it yeah i just
do me so you kind of just got your own
lane
you could just rock
yeah i'm on the shows all over the
country so i do one show every day and
it runs in a bunch of markets all over
the country so did you have that same
leverage uh your last lap at the station
no because when i the last time i worked
at the station
you know i moved from
i was in tampa and then i went tampa to
l.a and
a little pit stop in phoenix
um nah nah of course not no i mean you
know they gave me a great opportunity
and coming to l.a changed my life you
know what i'm saying so
yeah but like i was already thinking
like when i was in the pandemic and i
was able to like not have to go to the
radio station every day
and we were voicing our show from home
because
everything was shut down yeah
it gave me so much flexibility to like
get so much other money
yeah and and congrats on uh on the on
the situation man yeah so you know it's
just
it was already something i wanted to do
so it worked out man and doc winter
shout out to doc docks a real one ao is
a real one you know they they didn't let
me go because they wanted to clearly
they brought me back so you know uh
shout out to them what was good with the
uh with the with the artists you're
working with man oh yeah yeah you know
we got a little label that we're we have
ready set low label i mean it's little
right now
now but we just put a record out that's
doing well with um
t-pain uh featuring it's a lexus
featuring t-pain so yeah man we working
you what you wanna know some funny
i'm gonna just let y'all know how good i
am right
you see how i just went into journalist
j mode real quick i just like i just
started interviewing him he doesn't even
realize that this whole interview i've
been interviewing him just could this
could this be because you have some
journalist stuff coming down the
pipeline oh man i just
i've been in some media training since
june and people have been telling me how
to work this little media thing so why
did you get media training because of
our interview definitely
they're like yo
definitely i'm gonna tell you what
happened i went to miami i went to miami
right i was out there uh
for my boy birthday
and
i was kicking it i was actually out
there for vado birthday shout out to i
was out there for his birthday and we uh
pulled up on nori anytime i'm in miami i
always pull up on nori kick it with him
chop it up with him
never really take pictures post videos
and like that just kick it with him
same thing i was saying with you like
i've known you for years and
i never sent you a clean version of no
records right right because my
relationship ain't like yo can you play
this on the radio can you please radio
and nori was like you know what happened
at the bootleg kev interview it was a
great interview
he said
you just didn't learn how to create your
own click bait yet
he said when you learn how to create
your own click bait you're going to be
obese with this
you said you give them too much you
don't give them a chance to ask you
nothing
i said you know what
you're right and then when i you know
got this new situation
i had to learn how to like shut the
up
because i'm working with other people
and i'm in a writer's room and
it's like so i'm bringing ideas but it's
like
four or five other people with ideas
so you got to learn how to get your
off get your off quick shut the
up and then kick back
so i was just wanting to interview you
real quick wait so what are you so can
you talk about what can you talk about
anything yet yeah it's it's just some
media some media a new show it's a
upstart show
you know what i'm saying i don't want to
say that much but it's an upstart show
some new something that never been
done before
so it's not like
i can't go to nobody
you know what i'm saying like if i
really wanted to
i can't really talk to nori and get no
insight on it like if i wanted to hit
gilly right i couldn't hear if i wanted
to hit joe button i couldn't if i wanted
to hit you so it's going to be a hot is
it going to be a podcast or a tv show
it's a show okay you know what i'm
saying it's not a reality show i'm not
going on a reality show enough and it's
like are you hosting the white rapper
shows resurrection i'm hosting with mca
i'm not i'm not doing no like it's
something that never been done is some
i'm saying i'm excited to do i'm excited
for the people to see it i'm gonna let
them announce it and you know do the
immediate thing with it but i'm excited
it's some dope man it's some dope
i'm excited to be able to do
something that's not
so
i don't have to be rap rap rap like when
we was talking about the nod mm-hmm
the eyes don't really have to put out
no music right now yeah i'm glad he is
you know what i'm saying and but the
fact that he is
lets you know blood is yeah i mean
listen you love it he's doing it for the
money both king's diseases are i
actually think this new one is much
better than this they both they both
dope they both classic man and they just
feel good
[Music]
in their own way
i don't know about a cloud i mean that's
that simply is
i don't want to get up here and start
comparing this album to this album
because that's how you get in trouble
throwing that c word around i don't know
we'll see shout out to hit boy that's my
brother man shout out to hit boy shout
out to hit boy him hit boy and nas got a
real they got a real their dynamic is
insane dynamic it's great and the thing
is is like hit boy is a west coast guy
but he'd be getting in that bag man on
that on he's
yeah he's the goat i think hip boy is
like one of the greatest of all time
his range is insane the type of he
could do definitely definitely i got a
new project out called don't call now
i pulled up played with some joints
early before it came out you gotta let
me know he was with that that
that
made me feel why is that uh title
important
um
i kind of started recording don't call
now
i'll probably say before this summer
yeah
but
i kind of got caught up on this new
situation that i got right
and then i was at that point where it's
like
do you really even want to put this
out right now you want to just focus on
closing this deal and right right over
here
and i did i did that i did everything
that i had to do handling that all
through the summer so that's kind of why
i was just on some low handling
that but there's still something in me
that's like yo
put this he'll write this you got to
finish this song and it's like nah you
really don't
really just chill
and just get this bag right now but it's
something in me that's like yo
so then i had this moment where i'm like
damn
you figured it out my you
you figured out what's work what's going
to work for you right now right and it's
like damn
you don't even got a manager
you don't even got an agent no not a
publicist you don't got a pr person you
don't got none of that
so you went out and you closed this deal
dolo
so can't nobody say
but if it wasn't for me
no
everybody who could say if it wasn't for
me when they come to me
i'd have lost all that right
and i lost all that already so
anything that you could say if it wasn't
for me
god took that away from me i had to get
all this back on my own so don't
call now there's no reason for you to
hit me up now
because i don't need anything from you
now
so if you with me
cool but you don't got to hit me and be
like yo
yo bro no it was wild times i needed
that yo bro i didn't come out here and
be like yo my mental health was bad i
needed
uh you know you got kids you got my
fiance i got my mom's got my brother but
it was times where you feel like damn
ain't nobody with me like damn
what's the conversation when my name get
bored
it was times where i wondered that you
know what i'm saying there was times
where
it's that you done did millions
of verses for his when you was on
young money you was on tour and wayne
probably didn't even want you still
entertaining
that pith projects and like that
you still throwing on your
you getting no
but then when your ball kind of slowed
up on the field
like
yo bro can you can you uh post this for
me and for a while you do it and then
you'll be like
hold on you asking me to post some
for you that you ain't asking me to get
on right
that's i i can't even see myself
doing that so now it's like
no i don't call now man i figured this
out and
i ain't really pressed to get on get on
your mixtape or get on your album no
more right and you shouldn't be pressed
to get on mine because it's blatantly
clear that
we it's different but
maybe i'm just at that point in my
career where it's different and it's not
what it was with a lot of people it's
time for new relationships it's time for
new money right right i don't handle you
like
i ain't really got no history like that
with you so i'm about to pull up and rap
on your show right
it's like nah i with you like you
gave me valuable information
at a time where
you don't have to you could have just
said yo come rap on my and let me
get some views i was like nah you know
what i think you should do bro you know
what would be dope
i think you should blah blah blah right
you know what i'm saying and
i value that so that's why i don't
mind coming doing this type of this
that i'm doing right here i know my
interviews are monumental i know i could
talk i know i got wisdom i know i got
jews but now i'm at a point where i
don't even want to come talk to y'all
now right a lot of y'all i don't it's
like we could have been did this
i could have been came and wrapped and
chopped it up light up a blunt talk my
but y'all don't want that until they
announce what they gonna announce um so
that's real don't call it now man i'm
i'm gonna i'm gonna get a head start
like i don't even don't even
congratulate me it's it's
is it gonna is it already
attached to like a
major streaming platform streaming
platform yeah
so like a a hulu or a netflix type type
of platform i'm not saying either one of
those specifically yeah streaming
platform oh yeah platform huge film at a
nice lot
fire
rhythm and flow season two
[Laughter]
i'm not a judge on anything i don't know
i'm not a jedi you know but shout out
shout out to my team shout out to my
partners
you know i'm not going to keep guessing
i'm pretty good at the guessing thing
and i'll find this i'll tell you i'll
tell you off the camera okay okay
no that's big man um
you know what we didn't talk about so
you're from harlem definitely
uh
what were your thoughts on the lox dip
set
versus
uh i know it's been a while now but
i just curious you know obviously
dipset being the biggest entity to ever
represent that harlem flag you know
uh what were your thoughts on what
happened there i think
i think with the dip set locks versus
first of all shout out to the dipset
shout out to the locks
what they did with the verses was
monumental because you never seen it
like that that looked like a
concert
definitely you had never seen people
that close to the stage you had never
seen that many people on this stage
right never seen that people around she
was like summer jam or something that
was a it was a real event and
in in harlem fashion you know they had
to show up fashion be late you know
from yonkers was like get your
ass out here they made it a show and it
was entertaining right i like that and i
like the fact that even through watching
it i was like damn kim's they pulling
styles pulling cam's shoe and
oh no it was crazy they took the bandana
and threw it on the floor and then elves
and they was all in their face go uptown
to harlem and i'm like i love it but at
the end to see them be like yo we about
to go on tour
that did it
that did it for me it's like oh this
they did this for the city they did this
for the culture but now that we got that
out the way the the sequencing for the
songs for dips that i think was
we're gonna build up the momentum we're
gonna start out with this this and then
we're gonna get to this and then we're
gonna get to this
and i think the lox was like
nah y'all forgot about this ain't nobody
in the world you know hotter than kids
but they did the back and forth yeah
back to back then they're going into
freestyles then they go yeah i think
that was i think to me it was that was
like the showmanship and the performance
value of
and even with
just going in over who shot you without
a stand up i got to stand up for harlem
it was a few times and they was like
hold on they rapping over look this is
real hip hop we no vocals it was a few
of them songs they had the vocals but
addy addy kiss adi kiss was in rare form
i know that type of vibe that he was on
that wasn't jada drunk that was a
different type no jada was
lasered in but that was i'm getting
anywhere it's the best the best uh
verses ever
uh uh
i think i think it was the best one ever
i think it it it for me before that it
was the gucci uh jeezy one but the dip
said was way ahead look people i'm
sorry but
i'm kind of in journalist j mode so if
it feels like this is an interview of an
interview interviewing it's just don't
worry about it because i have questions
that i like to ask people because that's
my that's my job now so i like to ask
questions and get opinions
what did you think about the ja rule fat
joe versus we're always speaking out
verses
i miss great great transitions i
probably missed um
wonderful i probably missed like the
first 10 minutes i didn't see the whole
thing so i don't know how it started
um
i thought that
it seemed as if
the second half
i thought joe came out with a bunch of
records that he thought were like bigger
they were big maybe like on the rhythm
radio chart but they weren't like big
like in the oh
like he did the
that's what i think i think for the most
part ja rule controlled the battle but i
do think joe
made up for it at the end
so i thought it was actually pretty
close i know everybody's like job one i
was like i don't know it was kind of
close like it was the sequencing once
again
yeah i think i think fat joe ended it
great i think like if we're talking
about like i think fat joe won the
fourth quarter for sure i just think
like
i don't know i i just
i'm not sure
like what they thought was gonna happen
because fat joe has obviously got radio
records but he's also like
a part of ditc he's you know what i mean
and to go against ja rule
jabro really don't have that kind of
pedigree so the kind of records i would
have i would have liked to have seen joe
really tap into like i don't think he
did my lifestyle right he did he did see
i missed that part but this is the thing
you forget that job was on murda graham
you know what i'm saying you forget that
jaw even had them this is the thing it's
only 20 records so i missed jaw rule
doing halal hollow i didn't see that i
didn't see i i missed like a lot to be
honest but then once i started tuning in
i thought fat joe was leaning into the
jada a little bit too much
but it was cool i mean you know it was
probably my least favorite verses so far
and i love fat joe i like i liked it the
first thing is the versus thing is a
little
it was there was a point sometimes the
matchups could be there there was a
point in time where i was like this is
the worst versus battle ever but then it
started to get better in the job i
tweeted that i said this is the worst
versus battle ever i was glad to see
people be able to
like
remember like oh y'all had some
now general was a legend 50 came through
that 50 came through
and it's so ended it was career much of
like a a
like damn because john was suffering
like even like him performing clap back
right which was like one of the best guy
store beaches ever scott store
but what's crazy is when that song came
out
even though it was hard no one gave a
that was that was it was over unit
was steamrolling it was already over so
he put out even though clap back that
beat was crazy and i'm a jaw fan i'm a
50 yeah but like he before he performed
clapback like it was a joint and
everyone and i'm like yo this beat was
crazy this song was cool but like no one
gave a when this song came out
came on in there i mean you know that's
the thing about versus it's like where
is it how's that where's the presents
where it's like because i felt that way
about jeezy and gucci i was like
jeezy got way but gucci got a lot of
records but jeezy records was bigger
that's what i thought oh jesus you got
the biggest yeah i think record for
record jesus smokes gucci
the president says gucci
i think gucci just came out
disrespectful as and we've never
seen that like gucci literally came out
telling me i killed your man what are
you like what the is going on here
jeezy record for record and i love gucci
and i know that
in certain circles most circles gucci
know it can be gucci
but i think in the versus spectrum jeezy
washed him with that being said
it was close because of the disrespect
we've never seen that disrespect before
yeah that was wow
that was crazy but
fat joe ja rule i'm a huge fat joe fan i
think he's one of the most slept on
artists ever like lyrically like he's
one of my favorite artists of all i just
don't know man first album i had was
jealous one's envy like i just think
some of those records he performed
were cool
like that ass up face down record with
uh dre like i just don't think that
record
it was it was decent i don't know if it
was versus worthy
and i understand the point he was trying
to make i've still got right sometimes
sometimes the platform is so big
it's like how could i not
how could i not bring
my man out you know what i'm saying like
no no i ain't even that anymore
it's like it's not even him bringing dry
out i think he was trying to prove a
point that he still has current records
that have been coming out
but like some of those records might not
be the best fit for the platform of
verses in new york i got you how did you
feel about
how did you feel about uh
that joe performing
well i don't know performing but playing
the pun record
twins
i don't know i think i don't know i
think he played a pun record he wasn't
on i don't i didn't see that part that
had to be early
did he play uh because i i i i'm like
though there's no way he doesn't perform
twins no he did twins and he brought
random shout out shout out to him that
was dope that went don't see rem come
out and do punch party thing about like
joe is like
if it's i just i don't know man i don't
know him i i guess when you see it fat
joker's jar will make sense but i don't
think it made a lot of sense
i think fat joe's more like
got a lot more like of that real rap
that i'd like to you know if he
would if he would have went up against
jadakiss that would have made sense
but jada would have won
but it would have made more sense to me
because i'm going to look into the
camera and i'm going to say this right
who did jada battle this is a usa from
jay mills
jadakiss
cannot be in verses anymore there's no i
don't i don't think any sort of way that
he's involved in versus remember how
like on 106 in park they had to like
retire bow wow it was like all
right all right come on yo this is this
is
this doesn't even make sense yeah mr 106
in park
that i mean jadakiss is
mr versus
so i mean listen everyone and then i
knew a lot of people who thought fab was
gonna be and i'm like y'all are crazy
and shout out to fab this is a legend
this is one thing fab isn't like not
saying they had a 20th anniversary for
fab first i'm like fab
september 11th as as as a new yorker and
a and a dude who was like heavy in a
mixtape era at that time and used to buy
the
j um's instrumental freestyle you know
instrumental mixtapes and write my
freestyles to him
fab was like fab was like god to people
from that era
the stacking the punch lines on the
punch lines not waiting for the eighth
ball or the fourth bought it and i'm
coming in on the first barbershop i mean
yeah i hope all the soul tapes end up on
the dsps soul tapes are classics man
yeah
so tapes are classics and fab what's the
other one uh
fab's best unfortunately nothing is
something
the one with junior read
that song with junior read
gangsters don't play they have to join
with uh
t-pain that album was crazy that that
album was insane but i think fab's best
isn't on the dsps unfortunately like the
soul tape so i think this is best i
think that's his like
you know
and what what's the two tapes you just
put out uh
one the first one i loved
what the uh like vintage
80s 90s looking uh artwork
last two like the last two projects he
put out they were both i don't know he
just puts out a lot of mixtape and
i'm like bro
i think fab would thrive as an
independent artist
is fab and fab still on dev jam i sure
think so
probably
shout out to def jam no idea what they
do for their artists anymore
no clue like oh you're on def
jam what's that even mean anymore
uh fredo bang just asked to get off a
death jam shout out to fredo bank who do
you think
if you had to pair little wayne against
someone in the verses
who would he birdman said he would
battle himself i kind of feel i feel
like there's certain people that's just
like
nah no those certain people got to
battle each other i feel like wayne is
in that boat i feel like wayne is i
think it's drake i saw something today
right i saw a tweet
and it said
like a happy birthday wayne tweet and it
says some like
wayne been rapping for 25 years
he put out
x amount of albums 12 albums or
something like that said he gave us
nikki
he gave us drake he gave us young money
and he's still in his thirties
salute my wayne man when you think
about it wayne's not even 40 yet
nah man being weighing the same age
age so when i see some like that
it's like damn been rapping for 25
you've been not rapping for 25
that's crazy been in the industry on the
charts
bling bling every time we come right
here
25 years
gave you nikki gave you drake gave you
tiger
gave jay mills
you know what i'm saying
even if you want to be like yeah but
mills you was out before that he helped
rebrand me so i ain't going to
like not acknowledge that
you know what i'm saying
he did all the dedication to the carters
he did all that he went through his
ups his downs he bounced back went
through it with birdman all that
and still in his 30s hey
come on man he's one of them people no
he is no who do i think wayne could go
against him versus he's in he's in the
room where it's like him they keep
saying drake too i think drake is in
that room dre cove kanye drake hove
kanye beyonce mary j blige i don't know
snooping dmx i would have said no
i love mary but what but mary's not in
the room
mary's in that room no i think like mary
mariah carey mary ain't in there wrong i
honestly feel like jermaine dupree puff
dr dre pharrell they in that room too
i heard what jermaine dupree said about
he's in the songwriters hall of fame
this isn't a songwriter's version i
don't see a world in which mary could
beat beyonce universes
all those other all those other names
you mentioned you want to know this
question there's a world in which they
all can beat each other i don't think
it's about i don't think it's so much
you're messing them right no look
beyonce was in a group beyonce got
destiny child back she's not beyonce
beyonce
what i'm saying is all those names you
mentioned right don't listen listen
listen i am part of barry's not an
immediate i'm part of this now you
will not marry is a legend
[Music]
obliterate her in a versus battle it
literally would be
not a good look for mary to do that
it would be a horrible look beyonce
look bro bro
i thought
look mary is a legend you know what you
know when you said all those names you
know all those people could beat each
other no but but this is the thing this
is the thing i'm not saying who can beat
each other that's no no no no no no no
i'm saying that i'm also saying you
could put in that room mary's in that
room
mary's in that room i don't know i'm
telling you mary's in that room i don't
know what's the 4-1-1 my mariah's not in
that room
she ain't
she's not in the room she's in the room
next door with mary
[Music]
so you telling me mariah carey
and mary jane aren't in the room with
beyonce the room i listen no there oh
it's a room drake is in that room
wayne could be in there mary mariah
beyonce they're in that room missy she
in that room bro
no disrespect to missy no no listen
this is all disrespected you're saying
i'm not even gonna let you get away with
the journalist jay is in the building
let's get it going i cannot let you do
this i can't let you they are all in
that room i actually don't think
i don't think anyone's in the room with
beyonce
you could you if if if if you wanted to
put beyonce in the class by itself so
beyonce
she's got a loft above the house you
know why i don't get mad at you saying
that because beyonce because it may be
people battle beyonce look it may be
people that looked at that the same way
when birdman said that about wayne
so i get it it's it's to each his own i
get your opinion i'm just saying i have
a different i feel like they're all in
that room so i just feel like there's
certain people that i think there's a
tear below
the tier you're talking about and it's
like mariah may now i feel like that
is a it's a one level green room i
don't feel like i don't feel like
there's any tears i feel like they all
just sit in the room maybe
or maybe not i feel like i feel like
they're all in that room listen mariah's
a legend
i don't feel like jermaine dupri how
about this maybe i was a little
disrespectful to mariah because i said i
don't like me i don't want to say to the
germain i don't feel like i feel like
jermaine dupri
should be
like oh jermaine the preacher battle or
puffer
doctor is certain people that's like nah
you know what you know what jermaine
dupree missy
mary mariah
beyonce lil wayne drake jay-z
those type of people they in that room
over there like
you can't even get in from the outside
you got to wait for one of them
mariah did put out an and greatest hits
it was just called the ones you know
what i heard on the radio you know what
i heard on the radio the other day so
maybe mariah's in the room oh new york
in the house it's brook that's what i
said i just memorized that that's how
long her go back to maybe marisa i
should go back
no maybe mariah's in the room
go back man
i don't know mary's teetering on
yeah i don't know what is it what's good
with your man i love
i love mary the thing is mary has mary
mary's in that room
i mean we can agree to disagree we can
agree to disagree but i'm telling you
mary she's in that room man
again what's the fault
what's the four one one in my life we
can't put i could get married
we can't put anyone in the same room as
beyonce
female vocalist etc i i just don't know
rihanna might be in that room though you
said female vocalists
who's gonna be beyonce so so now you
just who's going to beat beyonce i'm not
i'm not saying who could beat who i'm
just saying but who's
i'm just saying who's in the room
i don't know mary is not close to
beyonce
i'm not saying that mary's not
incredible and influential and uh but
but who the
they're both in that room man
shout out to beyonce man shout out to
beyonce shout out to mary is nicki minaj
in that room
i think nicki is in that room too i
think nikki foxy
can come on
no no no no no no no no yo
you know why you see you know why i'm
gonna tell you not to put foxy brown and
little kim in the same room as beyonce
and nicki minaj
bro drake is in that room missing
i'm naming people that in a verses it's
like it's like now foxy brown is
incredible i love foxy broken
silences incredible album it's like nas
kendrick is in that room too man
kendrick in that room it's not i'm not
doing a a certain everything i'm just
telling you artists
that when you think about you know what
you know what's the problem they thought
that same thing with the locks when we
talk about the lock store oh dip
set got a cult following they got the
code following right but you forgot to
see you for all the locks but see you
forgot about the chain gang freestyles
on the illuminati
because i don't know if you was getting
those mixtapes where you was at so when
get on them stages and foxy start
performing verses from freestyles on
clue mixtapes when it was her a z nods
and carmego or nature and we remember
them because it's the it's the
boxes incredible yeah yeah when
kim start going into um i got no time
for four
foxy
if if they battle 20
if they battles winning if they battled
nikki only 20. it would be
see now you you now you know what you're
doing you're having people battle other
people that's excluded from the world i
like that i like a room in which
everyone has fair chances it ain't no
chances they worked hard enough to get
to the room but they ain't even in this
conversation
they're in a room they're not even in
this conference
you know it's crazy when the last time
you listened to monster one last time
you listened to monster you know like
four days ago i listen to my beautiful
dark twist of fantasy often
he in that room
who kanye he's in that room oh yeah but
but
when the last time you listened to
monster
four days ago
cool i was driving you think you don't
you think
she like you don't think she deserves to
be in that like i'm not even gonna lie
this isn't the thing it could be in the
room you know why i'm naming these
people that's supposed to be in this
room because versus and i've learned
this
and we're gonna talk about some other
because this ain't the versus
interview because
verses is
about performance
it's about stage presence it's about
personalities nikki's winning you know
it's about time and all of these people
i'm naming
i think when they get on that stage
it's a lot of times you might have the
better records
i think bow wow had better records than
soulja boys listen
soulja boy with one dude
and shout out to bow wash out soulja boy
you can't tell i didn't watch that
battle but i'm i'm i watched it
so i'm gonna going to tell you
soulja boy played she make it clap
four different times yeah because
soldier was going to hold him on record
but hold on he played his version then
he played the remix with french bought
french out then he played a version from
nicki minaj we never even heard that we
still haven't heard this verse he
played the same song three times no
he played a version of she make a
clap with nicki minaj that oh oh
you know what's crazy though soulja
boy is uh
she got intense one
minute soulja boy's records are way
bigger than bad weights hold on
journalist jay she got crazy soldier
boy's biggest song he might have is many
records but soldier was biggest records
are way bigger than bowwow's biggest
records
i'm just telling you i would have just
like teddy bears
baby face
not my harlem bias but i just i i
thought yo teddy riley it's teddy riley
and then i forgot i didn't i was like
damn i was like oh
babyface did this
he did this and i learned that
through the what's his name then he
bought out he bought it he said yeah
uh
this is when babyface fronted let me
show our babyface front he said yeah uh
play this next record right here uh that
broke out of acoustic guitar
i think he started playing when will i
see you again like singing it this is
before it was a stage he was singing
this to the instagram
had the feet tapping and i'm like damn
teddy wi-fi was up it was so much
going on it's like oh it doesn't matter
about
am i lying bro
it was like it don't even matter about
the wreckage no more right and i think
now reverses came to the stage
earth winning fire and the osley
brothers and swv and escape
these is groups where it's like yo they
both got hits so now it's all about well
who could sell it more who can who who's
gonna look better who's going who you
know bobby brown had a lot of hits who
would you like to say i would love to
see mary university sweat came up there
my my mom's was looking at the verses
like go ahead keith who
go ahead
who do you think would make sense
because i would love to see marianna
versus who who do you think she should
go against
mary versus missy might be solid
nah they're in the room man we gotta we
gotta talk about some look look i've had
media training right and it's what's
going on about what five months i've had
media training you're not gonna get me
to say mary the the mary and beyonce oh
that was i almost fell for it too i
almost said nah look beyonce america
they're both queens they're both in the
room they're untouchable
now beyonce's winning though
i don't i'm just going to embrace
greatness and just be happy that i i
don't even see it but
i'm good beyonce is winning
i don't know who who who would be you
know who wins
whoever's alive to see it fair enough
it's free
okay that's an incredible win we would
get to see that for free who would win
if drake and wayne battled on versus
because they did the tour the drake vs
wayne tour oh no
i don't think they would do it but it'd
be cool to see because they did do the
drake versus a little while who do you
think though so who'd you put your money
on
you had to bet a hundred thousand
dollars no i'm not betting on that who
but you had to someone said look you
know i don't have 100 i don't have to do
anything
make sure i i
uh fulfill my obligations to the
contract that i just said that's all i
have to really do i don't have to do
anything
but
i think i think both of them i think i
think drake and lil wayne
you know what's crazy to me it's crazy
to me to see like all of the records
that drake is breaking
in the time that he's been in the
industry
you know what i'm saying it's 2021 what
we
we finally got like drake drake like
best i've ever had so far yeah going
like what oh oh what that was on nine
2010. yeah think about like breaking the
beatles records and like like i think i
think
how many
likes i think drake's probably got like
he could probably do it versus with just
his features but i think wayne
can't get in the bag so he can he can
always in a versus battle say i signed
you
it ain't even about that i think i think
with wayne we forget it i would put my
money on it it was one year that wayne i
put my money it was on like 300
something records
involving like all of the links he had
from him and the features 20 verse 20
i'd put my money on wayne
just because i like i think that on
stage he'd
he'd do better and he could he could say
some slick that drake couldn't
answer to like i think reverse is just
hard to tell because it's about the
sequencing man sequencing is important
i think that performance at this point
it used to not be about performance
because people would just play songs and
then be on the ig live like
just think just think of where that
came from us watching it in the pandemic
in the crib
to now
it's it was slowing down money
i think the dip set lock put a
whole new energy behind it so shout out
to uh swizz and shout out to tim berlin
shout out to swiss and shout out to
timlin for keeping it going past the
past everybody being quarantined and
like that you know what i'm saying
that was some real to
figure out a way for people to get money
that did it before you know you gotta
think about like boy wonder and
hit boy you know that's a good one hey
what up man we got to interrupt the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at odd socks now when i be
riding for odd socks so hard man it's
because i really love the product they
got the most comfortable socks in the
world i got a pair of odd socks
basics on right now go get those they
got the socks wwe joints you know i'm
saying shout out to the undertaker pepsi
really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapateo underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these are
so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the ww they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview you know now that you're doing
uh tv stuff
and you're doing rapping just because
you kind of
love it right
yeah i love this man
my fiance
she be telling me
travis
stop lying you're never gonna stop
rapping you you love it
and i tell her like
i'm not gonna stop rapping
because i don't feel like we in an ever
right now where you have to retire or
you have to
i look at nah i look at some like two
chains i watch two i watch two chains
reinvent himself right to the point
where you don't give a how old two
changes right you know what i'm saying
you know kl fab is jim
jim don't die his beard you know you
don't give a how old jim jones is
nobody knows anymore you're like it used
to be a thing you put on el capo and you
like
it's talking yeah so i i i think
it's takers i think it's kind of yeah
shout out to heat makers it's kind of
like
at this point man this is how you was
just giving me some gain before we came
on camera about
you know how to keep going from
this point like what i'm doing like
certain work for certain people
right you know what i'm saying and i
feel like where i'm at right now
i love this so much i'm back to the
point where i was like
damn i don't i'm at a point where it's
like
do you want to do it do you need to do
it or do you have to do it you know what
i'm saying and with me it's like yo
i remember a time where i was doing this
and wasn't really looking for
nothing from it
and that was the most fun i've ever had
i wasn't obligated to even right now
with the empire i ain't obligated to
nothing i can drop something every day
if i want you know so it's not like an
obligation to anything you're free to do
what you want you're free to do
this new you know what i'm saying
and they're not saying i can't do my
music it's just like yo we just
need you to do this this blah blah this
is what we paying you for right you know
what i'm saying and
now it's like
yo bro you could really just do whatever
the you want i'm not looking
for
oh i'm trying to i got plaques already i
got plaques that i'm still waiting to
put up when i'm moving to the new crib
so it's like you're not doing it for a
plaque
and this is another thing this is
another thing i had to i had to learn
sometimes you could be chasing some
that you already got mm-hmm and i'm
explaining this to you i was ordering my
plaques and right and
i was ordering like
a young money gold album
i am not a human being album because i
was on two records on there and there's
platinum all right
get my plaque but i never really paid
attention to this type of so i
would go to producers houses and they'd
be like hell mills you
i would go to an engineer house and he
would be engineered on an album and he
would have a plaque and i wouldn't but
i'm on it and he was like yo order so
now i'm ordering my plaques billboard
plaques young money debuted at number
one hit number one the second album
debuted here soulless so this one was so
i'm like now i'm ordering all these
these plaques these young money plaques
so i'm like
you know i'll be on my geek
sometimes man
let me google
myself on billboard right
what did you see
so i was like damn i i google myself
look up the date back search and all
that
and i'm like damn i was on the billboard
charts when i was still living in my
mom's crib
i was on the billboard charts before i
was on the billboard charts with young
money but i just never knew
so i started ordering all them shits
order no no no ordinary
or the streets melting featuring swiss
beats i don't give a if it's number
20 if it peaked at 28
and it hit 43 or if it peaked that
number 12 and it was it dropped down to
80 something
it was there
so you need to see that every day so you
can know that's not something you need
to keep chasing
chase some other right wake up
every day roll you a blunt
look at that time where you was in the
hot 100 and you peaked at number 23 in
2004. was it hard hard to figure out
like kind of
how to
keep monetizing jay mills
yeah it was hard because
uh i didn't really have no real
management in the time where it was like
the whole roc nation or people are
signing into groups where you're not
you're not assigned to a manager you
assigned to a management group yeah
like i ain't really
i was just one of them people was like i
i know how to record myself i know how
to do all this i know how to put it
out i just put it out but i'm getting
lost in
nice people involved you need to be a
part of a system some sort of some sort
of machine if you just want to put the
music out and do the music you need
to be
with some people that could pick up
where you stop with the music they can
pick up with the rest of the business
right and i think i just got so lost and
i just like putting music out like i
ain't pressed on the
the bread the fame the numbers it's like
bro i'm gonna be real with you once you
haven't been on that
you haven't been around the world with
the whole young money and you don't
have to smack dvd to battle fame and
you know what it's like for flex to drop
bombs on your record and do that you
didn't you did
that's why i in the freestyle i say
i already did what i came to do all my
visions became true mm-hmm but i ain't
living in the past i'm living in it now
you know what i'm saying like
i was in that magazine that was the
first magazine i was in i remember doing
the interview in front of my mom i still
lived in my mom's crib when i did that
interview the people who can't see it on
camera it's the double xl with eminem 50
and eminem 50 cent and dr dre when 50
first got with them and i remember i was
like damn i felt so excited because i
had a whole page but this is coming from
being in the source and like off the
radar mm-hmm having like a a piece of
the paper remember that yeah
you're a part of like that and you
wake up you look at your plaques and you
look at your kids and you look at awards
and for award shows that
you wouldn't go to no more if they
invited you because you didn't
it's like you performed
i won
and if i never do it again i'm
grateful enough to know
yeah that's what god god put that in
your life for that moment
for you to get to some other you
know what i'm saying and
a lot of times i don't think people be
grateful
for the they already done
because sometimes you can't see it
you know what i'm saying that's that's
the whole thing with the black it's
like yo if you look at all this
you'd be like
am i really still trying to
like bust my ass to get on the billboard
charts or am i trying to get on a
billboard charge for you
like am i still trying to go platinum or
am i trying to go platinum for you
for you to be like see i told you my
could do it and i know i could do
it even if i don't do it i just choose
not to
do it because
got some other going on but when
you don't have nothing going on it's
hard how i'm talking right now is
talking from a standpoint where it's
like
yeah i'm up here don't call now is
available on our platforms
but
if you don't stream it my bills are
gonna get paid yeah it's important man
the range rover they're not gonna come
take it right i don't owe anything on my
jewelry i don't owe anybody anything
you know what i'm saying i don't feel
like nobody owe me anything
you know what i'm saying so i could talk
like this
and in my mind it's like
i see why when people get to a certain
point they just be like yo man
i'm doing this because i want to
like i don't have to you know i like
people be like i don't really have to do
this yeah that should just sound so
generic like right it's like nah i'm
doing this cause i love it so you
should love the that i give you
even more
just knowing i really don't have to do
this right right you know that's
fair um yo what was like the
creative process
let's go back to like a record like
bedrock or like a record like every girl
like how would you would you would you
guys record those together or would you
guys we recorded every girl and bedrock
together and once again i'm going to
speak to the genius of wayne real quick
wayne
formulated that whole every girl bedrock
type uh
wayne changed my whole verse around on
bedrock the but the end it was the
beginning and i think the beginning was
the end but he was like yo it sounds
better on a walk-in just that he
known from being with the hot boys and
like that he shared that with us
like he used to always
share that with us like yo i'm
gonna get on these records with y'all
like i'm gonna sell it with y'all i
ain't just gonna throw you all out there
so that's why he was on every girl he
was on bedrock he was on this he was in
the videos he was bringing us on stage
with him he was he was doing all of that
because he was trying to sell it so
really that was wayne ideal to bedrock i
mean every girl video
with all the different type of girls
getting out the video like skinny girls
big girls small girls white girls black
girls this religion this religion that
was his idea to make it seem like we
like just kept getting out the car
like yeah we just gonna be in a factory
with the car we just going so drake
nicki j mills everyone's in the studio
together during this time
no not for every girl nikki bullied her
way on bedrock shout out shout out to
dicky she she was like no you're not
gonna put out another single without me
like because every girl was like
something that we just did
and she's not in every girl right no
yeah that's yeah every girl was
something we did and
uh
i want to say hollywood somewhere
or somewhere like up there of sunset you
know them like the hotel they got a
studio in the hotel i forgot it's one of
them sexy shits like on the
on the whatever long story short we did
it in there and yeah we was all in there
together that's crazy he was all in
there together when we did bedrock uh
when we did bedrock
lloyd wasn't under the marion was on it
when we first when we first did it and
they got leaked and i think uh you know
wayne on here and with no leaks
so when they got leaked like they was
trying to like switch it up still use
the record but just that's why when the
final record came out it was that it was
i will say this man
wayne don't get enough credit
for a lot of
like with the whole young money
like we was when you think about where
we was at with it like drake was drake
from degrassi and nikki was nikki from
the from the dvds and the mixtapes and
gucci and all that she was doing
and i was me from the smack dvds and
mixtapes and all that but
wayne was wayne he was on the verge of
because it was right before lollipop he
was on the verge of becoming wayne wayne
right right when he became wayne wayne
a million record soul first week
carter three
he took everybody mm-hmm you know what
i'm saying even if if before it was
artist bus and we all had different
buses
it was
challenges on my bus
you know what i'm saying and i give him
a lot of credit for that because he
didn't have to put us on the stage with
him
at the height of his you know i'm
saying i can't think of too many
artists at that time
of his
like
level
that was doing the that he did for
us
was there ever anyone that you knew that
almost signed with young money that
didn't end up working out that would
have been crazy
uh
damn i don't know
i don't know i can't really i can't
believe it was it was a it was a few i
remember mario and i thought that was
gonna be cool the whole of marion thing
i don't know what happened with that
i remember lloyd lloyd uh
i don't know it was you know people was
probably hitting wayne up like crazy i
remember one day i was with wayne
and he was like yo boys just hit me up
about getting with young man i was like
he was like nori noriega this is like
this is like a while this is like when
nori was uh doing reggaeton
kind of probably around that time he was
still nothing there he was still booming
he was still booming yeah probably
nothing
reggaeton mikanto one of them and shout
out to nori man like
nori one of them people uh
i don't really speak to him
too much
but when i speak to him he always tell
me about myself
he always always
and i used to
i used to go back and forth with him you
know because we probably smoking and
drinking right right and it's probably
coming across like yo
and
i had to realize like yo i used to
listen to this man
when i was in the 9th 10th grade
eleventh grade you know i used to ride
to school and listen to the war
reporting
n-o-r-e and
first time i heard fab was on a clue
freestyle with nori on air oh wow
wrapping up with money power respect so
when i talk to people like that
it's not really about rap no more it's
like i don't really care about doing a
song with you
like
i ain't really even tripping on
doing a drink champs interview
hey i'm sure that i'm gonna tell you why
because
i feel like
i get more from you answering the phone
answering a text message you know what
i'm saying or
if i'm in town like yo i'm here i bet
link up let's link up
i get more out of that than trying to
get some publicity
or market something or like nah you
interviewed this one i need to come
promote it's like nah man just answer
you know what i'm saying and it's like
that with a lot of people like shout out
to young guru you know what i'm saying
like
sometimes i just hit guru like yo just
checking in just saying what's up you
know like once i like was in the studio
with him he kicked it with him and he
started telling me oatmeal's
it'd be crazy if you take your battle
and turn it into an nft and it's like
and i'm sitting there like yo this is
jay-z's
engineer like he's giving me game right
i mean his crib giving me game open his
door to me you know what i'm saying i
value
like that more than
yo let's do some music
it's like i've been doing music for 20
years man would you do battling anymore
i probably would but
not at this present moment like i got a
lot of bags gotta be right
oh the bag got to be stupid right the
bag was right when i came back so yeah
yeah and i'm saying the bag was right
when i came back but there's so much
money in the battle rap man good
transition this is a good trend
journalist j good transition
i was watching uh was it summer madness
the other day
you know you don't keep up with the
battle the battle culture man i i used
to and it just became like it just
became alive
uh battle culture yeah shout out to
smack shout out to url
uh shout out to caffeine shout out to
caffeine
shout out to uh i saw the gichigadi
calico joint
uh mooc reed
uh shout out to shawn k sean battle
uh
chess
easy
see these is people
and i noticed this i noticed with my
platform and with my new platform and
like that when you speak about
these type of things you gotta highlight
you can't just glaze over because i
was one of those battle rappers before
that
a only shout out to headliner like
yeah shout out to mook and this one it's
like nah it was a lot of other up
there that got busy that day mm-hmm
there's a lot of other that went
to work that day you know what i'm
saying they was up there trying to get
it back and hoping that don't bump
him hoping the you know what i'm
saying so
i still try to keep keep uh keep myself
tapped in with that coach that's why
when you ask me when i still battle it's
like hell yeah shout out to head ice
had ice ain't no young young boy
but he hear god with the battle
rap that's another sport where
father time don't catch up with you in
battle rap
father time don't catch up with you and
rap i just watched knives winning grammy
i was with nori in miami when nas won a
grammy
and he was facetiming he was hitting him
like yo you did that for queens like
i was with nori speak like just how
everything just come full circle you
know what i'm saying it's like i was
i was with him when he facetimed now i
was like yo you just like
it's just moments like that for me now
it's past music
it's past trying to create a musical
moment like i can't
i don't want to hit two chains
and be like yo i need a verse like you
did a verse for me when you was charging
a hundred thousand right all i want for
my birthday is a big booty girl mills
just send it you ain't never got it you
never got it it's
it's certain people
that did for me
uh
when i was coming up in my music career
throughout my music career when i might
have been out of down time and
you know i needed i needed some some
help with some
there's a lot of people that might have
helped me with things
and right now people might be like yo
why you don't hit so-and-so for a
feature why you don't hit this one for a
feature
it's like nah cause that person already
did
for me that
i don't even give a about the
feature the other that they did was
more important that meant more to
me like now i'm more into some like
yo
can i uh get you
for my uh how many minutes can i get you
for for this segment i got right you
know i'm saying that that'd mean more
than me with me now and this new
i'm doing cause i ain't gonna keep
asking you for no and to keep the real
majority of the people that did a lot of
for me in the industry did it for
free
i can't really tell i could probably
count on
three fingers the times i paid for a
feature
now look at which features were those
now i ain't gonna throw them out there
like come on who'd you pay for you gotta
tell how much who'd you have to pay for
you wanna know something crazy they all
from new york so who'd you pay for nice
i would because i
wouldn't want to put it out there but
i'm just saying people pay for features
no people do but i'm just trying to show
the love
that i've gotten
from everyone else first came in the
game through ups and downs before young
money wit young money after young money
my independence
like when i was just a mixtape
with no with no nothing
i know you had mentioned that you and
vito might be doing something like a
project is that something that's still
even on the table like
yeah uh
you know what it is with the german
envato we always go back and forth like
we're going to do this go do that never
get around to it so i don't know but v
is my boy vs
v is like
one of my best friends in life
like i knew vado before we was both
rappers i think he was the first guy
like i i remember the slime it was
he was
and we got that from nori
and uh we got that from nori saying that
in the video like
yeah no it was nori and then vado and
then yeah yeah so we say that we
acknowledge that we from
we from that era we formed the era of
like how we was talking earlier about
like stretch armstrong and you know kim
and joelle's going up to stretch your
arms stronger
or major figures going up to stretch
armstrong
shout out to shout out to gilliam shout
out to the major figures man i don't
i don't speak on a lot of this a lot but
i remember when major figures was like
the thing right
and i was one of them kids i used to be
listening to stretch armstrong on
sundays
taping it
you know because
i know when whoever come up here they're
going to rap whether it's eminem and
royce
whoever is royce by itself that's how i
found it like yo this royce the
five nine is nice because
you know so
i noticed gilly in them would come they
go up there they mob they kill it they
flown they spit and they got this
down
but one thing i always used to notice is
i know that this show is being recorded
in new york
so that means they came from phil they
come from a whole another state
this royce the five nine and then
they came from a whole another state to
come up here and just right right just
get this off
at that time to me
that's what i wanted to do
it's like i just want to go everywhere
and get my off i want to rap i want
these right you know what i'm saying so
it reverts right back to the like yo
even if i wasn't making no money off a
rap
i'd probably still talk my were you
around uh
young money cash money when gilly was
around no or was that prior to you i
wasn't around for that i was that was
before me that was before me yeah
yeah it's crazy to think like
the the folklore of whether or not he
helped wayne wright
i don't think
i don't think gilly wrote for wayne but
wayne is the type of person if you're
around him and you nice it ain't i ain't
gonna act like i don't know you nice
it's like yo i got some
yo tell me how you think this sounds and
if you'd be like
uh
i think on the other part you could have
said that like uh i'd be like good
idea
yeah good idea good looking good looking
i appreciate that i bet
it's probably some like that you
wrote for me you you write for me right
right cause you might not even be as
nice as me
you write for me and i'm not saying like
the gillian wayne but i'm just saying
like
i'm one of them people my boy sitting
right there them and many times like
once we done got comfortable enough to
the point where
he don't look at me like oh that's big
bro i can't just tell them like you know
i don't want to tell that once it
got to the point we could be like
um
you should say it this way
yeah or you can deliver that better and
now and then it'll get to a point where
he'd be like
i think what maybe you probably could
have said like
instead of saying this it's cool
does that mean you write for me i just
sat up here and told you on bedrock
the end was the beginning the beginning
was the end
wayne told me hey mills you come out the
booth real quick
i think you should start it off
she ain't uh and when she miss that's
that's better and then leave the other
part for the other does that mean wayne
right for me right right it's my man
this is my boy we working on the same
product
you know what i'm saying that but that's
how i look at it
that's just me you know what i'm saying
other people might look at it like now i
don't be wanting nobody to help me with
nothing all right cool
if it's me
and this
all right let's just say at that time
it's me it's gutter gutter it's tiger
it's wayne this is drake it's mcmahon
it's nikki
before we even go in the booth
we're going to say our verse for
everybody
in a circle yo turn that turn that down
real quick i get it everybody like this
i don't think we're the only crew that
used to function like that
i think before you go in the booth cam
wanted to hear your too right and
cam gonna be brutally honest and wayne
gonna be it was times
some people might not make it to a song
it was songs i didn't make it to because
wayne might hear that and be like
nah
you cannot
oh he might get to the studio and we
already didn't put verses on before
he got there he played back listen to it
like
oh oh no nils got it gotta kill you on
that one
take that verse off right
i'm gonna say
yeah you guys what i'm saying at that
point it's like okay we probably about
to do eight more records tonight you're
not thinking you're not thinking about
it like that when you're in that crew
mode and you and that it's my we
bombing on we just bombing on you
know what i'm saying you're not thinking
like that and i think
tde he wasn't thinking like that q ain't
in there with absol and kendrick and all
of them when they was doing their things
right it's like
you're just bombing on you're just
bombing on yeah that's that's a
fair point um with the new thing you're
a part of you can't speak on all the way
yet
right
that's on shout out to my partners man
some sort of like
what made you
i guess want to pivot out of
doing the
music more and doing the video
and then maybe kind of
be more of a personality
um
i'm about to sound crazy right now
uh
well i could me and my boy my boy shout
out to my boy linux if anybody really
been following me they know uh in in the
pandemic when the whole quarantine
started we started a podcast
my boy right there we started a podcast
called
the loud opinions podcast right
i would pull up at his crib
we invested in some lights
some speakers some mics
i got a laptop with garage band let's
get a mixer let's figure out how to the
inputs and how to do this all right
that worked
set up my osmo pocket right here you got
an iphone 11 i got iphone xr let's order
some amazon tripods
it i think that's how it worked i
filmed you from this angle
i'm gonna film me from this angle and
i'm gonna film both of us on this angle
go home get on youtube learn how to
edit multicam right right right so now
i'm editing our
we ain't getting no views like that you
go pull it up right now
real i ain't gonna lie you can pull
it up right now
ain't getting no views like that but
we're doing it
probably did about
four 14 15 12 12 12.
probably like 14.
we do like 14 episodes right
so we kind of had a point like yo what
is what are we doing you know what i'm
saying is this working is it worth
it do it make sense
we fell back off doing it
i put out wood panel walls
so when i put out wood panel walls by
now
we're shooting videos i'm telling him
like bro i know angles i got the camera
to the point where he wouldn't bought a
camera bro
let me get nice through shooting videos
by shooting your videos he was paying a
dude to shoot his videos you don't gotta
pay me nothing i'm your boy
but when i need a video done you could
i'll show you what i know
and in return we can just bang out so
we're doing that we're shooting videos
and so now from the podcast i
learned how to edit
that taught me how to edit the videos so
now i'm shooting the videos i'm editing
the videos i do wood panel walls i'm
like yo let me try some i'm just
trying you know what i'm saying
trying to get more attraction with the
project
i'm like let me do like a little
documentary so i set the tripod up in
the studio film myself talking i take
pictures videos also make a little
documentary
the dude
i later found out the dude who came to
me with the opportunity for the job
uh shout out to my boy harrison
he came to me with the situation
and i thought it was fake
i thought it was fake and i was like yo
just tell me
how much y'all could pay me
for what y'all need me to do
you know what i'm saying
so he told me and i'm like
all right
because
you got to be my own got no manager i
got no agent i don't know nothing i just
happened to check the email one day and
it was like yo we want you to do this
let me just reply to this so i
replied to it and i'm gonna just fast
forward to the point of what made me
want to transition he was like yo
he's 23 24 years old so i had to ask him
like yo what made you think that this
was
what the made you come to me you
know what i'm saying and think that i
could even do this i don't have no
history in doing this enough and
what made you
and he was like yo
i saw your podcast
i watched your podcast episodes
and i watched your documentary he said
and then from there
i went and looked at your battles and
all of that
so
i'm like damn if we wouldn't have never
been doing the podcast
and i wouldn't just still have that
there for you to go look at 15 episodes
of personality right and range in
different conversations and laughing and
joking and all of this
you might not have that opportunity i
might not have the opportunity if i
never would have did that documentary
that at the end when the credits rolled
it say directed shot and edited by
jarvis j mills mills you wouldn't have
came to me and gave me equity and made
me an executive producer and brought me
in the writers room for some reason
but you already know i could do this
so when i'm
like yo this is too good to be true
they like nah this is this is this is
destined for you this is perfect for you
that's fire man you know what i'm saying
so when you it's like yo god brought
this to me that's why i'd be like can't
nobody be like if it wasn't for me if it
wasn't for you what you ain't got
nothing to do with this
i don't even have a team of people
that i got to split my with now
right which is even better it's crazy
you know i'm just even better
you know what i'm saying so with that
it's like yo
and i could get up here and be like when
you ask me do you want to would you
still battle again no i don't need
the battle i'm over
it's like nah i love that
i would probably still battle for free
you know what i'm saying because it's
not it was never about them and people
gonna see that yeah they're gonna see
they're gonna see that now with this
this era of j mills you know what i'm
saying i'm engaged i'm planning
a wedding okay good luck with that you
know i'm saying i appreciate that man so
i'm married
planning the wedding is the least fun
part about that but it's fun to me
yeah you know what i'm saying it's it's
fun to me because there's some news and
you got to figure out who to invite who
not to invite okay how many how much is
that
let's talk how much is it per plate oh
no no we're going to cut about 50
that's the problem this is
the problem my fiance she's gonna like
this part of the interview
i'm gonna talk about this wedding
too right
yo why people just think that they're
gonna be invited to your wedding
i don't know what at what point in life
did this start when people just
tell you yeah cause that's your way and
i'm a
nah you might not even be at the wedding
what are you talking about i had about
85 people at my wedding
was like if i
you vaccinate it man yeah you want the
blank yeah how do i hit the blunt thing
man
i'm not vaccinated
but you told me that after i hit the
blood
the way he said it was like yo are you
vaccinated because i cool you can hit it
there he's like oh by the way i'm not
vaccinated then i was gonna tell you
enjoy that corona i was gonna tell you
jesus i get tested i get tested here i
get tested every week right
and my daughter kids they get tested at
school all of that guy just hit me with
the but i heard in
i heard uh in like i don't know if it's
new york or new jersey
i heard they're not testing the kids
they're only testing
uh
the teachers i could be wrong
i could be wrong but
i would be real nervous if the kids
wasn't getting tested because kids is
like they real careless and they just
plus you won't even know if they have it
because most of the time if a kid has
coronavirus they don't they're usually
asymptomatic
that's true so you might not know you'd
be like kicking it with with your kids
taking them over to grandma grandpa's
house
grandma and grandpa die yo you you know
you know what you know what uh
i was
just telling you about the song and
feeling like mellow right
it's so crazy like i always tell you
like
anybody who know me know carmelo anthony
my favorite basketball player you know
not i'm not saying he's the best he's
your favorite that's fine right of
course
so been following them since high school
so
i always used to like
kind of like run my career like parallel
to mello or some
and i always used to science be like yo
you know what's so crazy
the only thing i'm missing
is like
a solo major album
that has done all of these miraculous
numbers that but
it's like what damn is that for me
or is that for
argument's sake of the fans or
argument's sake of your friends and
people that
because for me
i did way more than i thought i would
right when i when i step back and i look
at
awards and plaques and i look at
like that and how long i've been doing
this people come and go people
don't last 20 years
you know what i'm saying like i'll be
trying to tell people like bro i was a
kid i came in this like i got my first
deal at 17.
i was a kid rapper kind of you
know what i'm saying the book do the
battle and do didn't do all that so
when you when you when you get to this
point man
you be grateful for a lot of you
don't look down on nothing you you try
to look at what's gonna be the
next move what's gonna be the next
what's gonna be the next uh
the next thing that i could be a part of
on some j mills branding myself not
like i'm a rapper it's like nah i rap
you know what i'm saying i
i
i rap
i direct i produce
i write you know what i'm saying so
everything
bringing it back to the to the mellow
it all everything
with me is like
always felt like the underdog so i
always felt like i had to do more i
always felt like i had to put out more
freestyles i got to put out more
mixtapes i gotta i gotta post more
tweets i gotta i gotta be because i
can't get lost in
and
in trying to do that it's like
are overlooked
all the you did so i make you step
back and they'd be like hold on what you
did what
what you did and then when i had my down
time that's why i said to them bars i
was telling you it's like yo
i could see how mello could feel like
damn so it's always me
so i'm always the problem all right cool
i'll take that
last time i would say i said bro
anything that ever happened in my career
i take the blame for it i can't blame
nobody else
i'll take the blame before i blame
somebody else because i sleep better
like that you can rewind to the last
interview i said the same thing
mello took the blame for a lot of
that wasn't his blame you know wasn't
his fault but he still took the blame
for it
when he was out the nba ragged
them
and they got over he came by he came
back portland did his thing did his
thing yeah proved he could still now
it's oh mellow mellow melanoma
don't call now
i'd be prepared for that that
that's what i always say man
been in this for as long as i've
been in it you're gonna have some ups
and downs
you know what i'm saying but it's about
how do you handle the ups and downs how
do you deal with people
that when you came back down they showed
you what it really was
that's something i'm saying you gotta
you gotta learn that man like
that's some you gotta i had to
learn that
thinking everybody your friend everybody
your homie yeah if i thought everybody
was my homie or everybody was my friend
i would go sit and do this with
everybody all right i know everybody
that's fair i know him i know what
they're doing i know when they shows
come on and
there's plenty of times that you could
have had me come sit down right
listen to me talk
you know what i'm saying like it was
plenty times where could've are
you gonna do the podcast uh
you know with the new situation that
might be how would it make sense for you
to try to bring the podcast back i was
thinking about bringing the podcast back
you know they're not telling me like i
can't do no
no other like that so and that's
the end
just the beauty of it like when i was
looking at the contract it's something
that i already was doing
before this
so something that was already in motion
you can pull it up and see that i was
doing it so it's not like i took a new
job right right right
well we can't wait to see what it's
going to be hopefully we'll be
announcing it soon the album is out
we're going to have yeah we'll have you
come back in like six months
six months whenever you announce this
i'm just waiting for them i'm just
waiting for it for the announcement and
a little press release thing
and then i'm right back here rhythm and
flow season two rhythm and flow season
two with jay mills
judge and host coming soon in netflix
really soon
i'm just kidding shout out to my people
i have absolutely zero inside
information so if i guess that correctly
it was not um your fault
i'm not on netflix there it is not
netflix
so he's gonna be on hbo max
anyway appreciate you man hey look
jmills go get the album don't call now
and the freestyle is out so go watch the
freestyle oh yeah i'm nice man come on
i'm i'm always going to be nice i'm
always going to be always can't lose
that is what it is boom